if you observe the universe carefully
every element in the universe is
constantly serving everyday I'm trying
to plant seeds of gratitude and I
recommend doing it the first thing you
do in the morning but even more
importantly the last thing you do before
you go to bed Marcus Aurelius once said
it's not death that we should fear we
should fear never beginning to live need
motivation watch a top ten that would
believe nation
he's Jai Shetty and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success volume 6
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one tap into the way of the universe I
was looking at life and going what do I
want my life to be about and I swore
successful people who were depressed I
saw rich people who were sad and I swore
famous people who in the end had to find
a new way of getting happy and just this
week as we're talking we saw what having
a Kate Spade and Anthony Bourdain and
rest in peace to both of them and you
know blessings and our best wishes and
prayers for both of them yeah and then
billion millions a lot of people in the
world that we don't know about like in
the people that we don't talk about and
we don't see because they're not famous
and well-known at 18 I was awakened to
the belief and understanding that if I
did not focus on my consciousness there
was no such thing as happiness and
meaning if I didn't go inward there was
no chance of longevity in any form
because I saw all of this around me so
what I sworn the monks I was different
is that they almost had tapped in to the
way of the universe and I'll explain
what I mean by that what I mean is that
if you observe the universe carefully
every element in the universe is
constantly serving constantly the water
provides us with energy the trees
provide us the nutrition the oxygen is
just fueling our bodies and it's taking
nothing from us yeah you look at the
tree when you take shade of a tree the
tree doesn't say that will be two
dollars yeah right the teeth it might
think about this all the time in the air
I really yeah yes it's so many things
now we're bottling up air and selling it
oxygen buzzes but but the point being
that there is every element the Sun is
giving light yeah and it is growing our
plants and vegetables the rain is
growing our plants and vegetables are
given every element in the universe is
serving and when I learn as a monk and
when you speak about this and we just
experienced it so deeply when we were
there is the only way to be aligned with
the universe is to serve because then
you're acting in alignment because the
universe is serving so when you're
serving you are now in the universe
you're not with the universe the
universe is your ally whereas as long as
you're trying to serve yourself and be
greedy
you're not working against the universe
so when people talk about like the
universe has your back or you should
work with the universe or be aligned
with the universe that's what it means
universe isn't about all universe I want
a big car like give it to me that's not
being a land of the universe right
being around er the universe is choosing
service right as your focus rule number
two grow from rejection we should
actually be extremely grateful that some
things don't work out the way we once
wanted them to when we get rejected or
we fail or things gonna go away we feel
we're further away from our goal but
sometimes it's in those moments that we
have the greatest opportunity to reflect
refuel and refocus it's in those moments
that feel like the death of our dreams
that our truest potential is actually
taking birth if a door doesn't open it's
not your door
often we're trying to climb ladders that
are not ours to climb is your dream
really your dream are you chasing what
you truly want I remember one of my
mentors telling me that in our pain we
find our greatest power success is not
built on success it's built on failure
it's built on frustration it's built on
fears that you have to overcome
sometimes it takes a good fall to really
know where you stand every time when we
think we're being rejected from
something good remember we're just being
redirected to something better rule
number three plant seeds of gratitude
speak about gratitude for a minute
absolutely so one of the things about
gratitude is that studies show that when
you're in gratitude when you're feeling
gratitude you can't be in another state
so you can't be angry or sad or
disappointed when you're being grateful
so grateful for me is like a seed and
when you're grateful you plant this seed
in your life which is gonna grow a
beautiful tree and shade and fruits and
it helps you avoid what I call weeds in
our life so we're planting sadness or
disappointment or anger these like weeds
in our life
so every day I'm trying to plant seeds
of gratitude and I recommend doing it
the first thing you do in the morning
but even more importantly the last thing
you do before you go to bed because when
you do it before you go to bed you wake
up with gratitude in the morning so it
programs your mind to be grateful the
next day rule number four change your
perspective Marcus Aurelius once said
it's not death that we should fear we
should fear never beginning to
when we die a lifeline does this when
we're alive a lifeline does this notice
how that connects with our real
experience of life life is full of ups
and downs it means you're alive twists
and turns love and loss happiness and
sadness success and failure we
experience extreme highs peaks and
summits and at the same time experience
the troughs Bulow's and submit life is
kind of like one big crazy roller
coaster it starts slowly fills you with
anticipation and curiosity takes you up
and then sends you flying down only to
rise up quickly
again we laugh and fill it hurts we cry
inside a little experience a few moments
where we wanted to stop and hope it's
all over but it just keeps going we
somehow think that success is linear an
upward line there is literally no case
study for that everyone we admire has
ups and downs your body mostly replaces
it
of every seven to fifteen years the
organs that work the hardest have the
fastest changeover
you get a whole new skin every two to
four weeks your red blood cells lost
less than half a year and your liver
renews itself at least once every couple
of years the universe is always changing
we are always changing but we want to
remain the same we settle for security
not recognizing that a flat life line
means we're dead real life is ups and
downs death looks like this we cannot
avoid the ups and downs but we can
change the way we see them because as
Wayne Dyer said when we change the way
we look at things the things we look at
change also if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check out my 250
for confident series it's free the link
to join is in the description below get
that gold get that dream and I'm just
been telling you drive it and drive it
and drive it and drive it what I've been
talking about is consistency if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about until
I become fearless why not find some time
every day to practice becoming fearless
rule number five wake up awakening
signifies that we're asleep when you say
we have to become woke or awakened or
any of these words that were using now
write it rising above it all means that
we're asleep so even though we think
we're awake we're saying we're
consciously asleep and therefore the
earth people around us conscious
creators everyone you've mentioned are
simply all trying to wake each other up
and we all know that when you don't wake
up in the morning the alarm just has to
get louder and louder and louder and if
the alarm doesn't get louder and louder
and louder
louder we don't wake up and so if you
see the earth in a state of emergency if
you see the environment in a state of
emergency if you're looking at the world
in a state of emergency it's because the
alarm is just getting louder and louder
and louder and trying to say wake up
like like wake up you know and so for me
that's the process that we all need to
go through just as it's tough to wake up
in the morning after you've been out to
a party you've had too much to drink
you've done something that you weren't
proud of or you've wasted your time just
as it's hard to wake up every morning
when you've done that the night before
it's hard to wake up consciously when
that's all you've done for lifetimes
like when that's all you've done for
your whole life
yeah that's how hard it is and I think
that's why we struggle because we all
know how hard it is to just wake up the
next morning when you've had a late
night yeah imagine you've been having
late nights in your consciousness for a
long period of time rule number six be
patient the biggest pressure I think we
feel is we're rushed by other people's
timelines
we're rushed by the success and
achievement of people around us or we're
rushed by the supposed success and
achievements of others we see on social
media and the biggest thing I'd say is
give yourself permission to take time
give yourself permission to recognize
that living your passion and creating a
purpose takes time for some people have
waited till 30 or 40 or 50 or 60 we
wanted to happen in our 20s but your
best years are yet to come
rule number seven fill your cup with
positives a businessman was rushing down
the street because he was late for a
meeting it was a really important one
and he wanted to make it there on time
it was at that moment that this
bumped into him and made him spill all
of his coffee all over his brand-new
suit now not only was he late for this
important meeting but he was also
covered in coffee
he was totally furious frustrated and
angry of what could he do now if we ask
this simple question
why did he spill the coffee the obvious
answer is because someone walked into
someone who wasn't paying attention
bumped into him and that's the wrong
answer
the real answer is he spilled coffee
because that's what was in his cup if he
had tea in his cup he would have spilled
tea if he had orange juice in his cup he
would have spilled orange juice if he
had water in his cup he would have
spilled water whatever is inside our cup
is what will spill out when life will
come and shake us rattle us or push us
which is inevitable it's what we're
holding on to or what's inside of us
that spills over and when that happens
what comes out could be anger
frustration pressure or stress or it
could be forgiveness joy and empathy so
we have to ask ourselves what's in our
cups when life gets tough
what spills over is it gratitude healing
kindness and compassion or is it
negativity toxic feelings and beliefs
and pain when things are going smoothly
we're not even aware of what we're
holding on to or what's inside of us
sometimes we don't even recognize and
identify something until we're shaken
and feel something negative happens
today let's be proactive let's start by
filling our cups with forgiveness
kindness and empathy so that when we're
shaken
that's what will come out rule number
eight find your real self we're so lost
in these false identities in the same
ways the body is one identity like and
then the second identity is oh well I'm
from the US you are from the UK I'm from
India you are from Africa that's one
other identity it's another layer we've
added to ourselves then another one is
I'm from this city like rep my city
right like I'm represent a might say I'm
New York versus Chicago versus London
versus whatever and then beyond that
it's like my sports team right now it's
like my family now it's now it's social
media yes now it's social media it's my
following my base and it's like we are
constantly ruining our own understanding
of our own real identity must be by
putting on fake costumes yeah and it's
like becoming a method actor right like
we're all method actors where we're lost
in the identities we've created for
ourselves so I I often like to think of
it like Inception yeah like we have lost
ourselves in an identity in an identity
in an identity right like that which I
think you have talked about this before
that perception all the way perception
yeah one of my favorite quotes when
clearly is I'm not what I think I am I
know what you think I am I am what I
think you think I am and and we we lose
ourselves in that yeah but I want to I
want us to almost like we pull back it's
like falling down a well yeah and like
being so deep or falling into the ocean
and being so lost deep and you need
someone to come and pull you out yeah
it's almost like that's what we all need
to do with ourselves
rule number nine make an impact there
are three things that control our lives
time wealth
and help when we're young we have time
time to play time to explore time to
waste time to be curious when we're
young we generally have health we have
energy we have strength but most of us
don't have wealth we don't have all the
money in the world we can't buy
everything we want we don't get
everything we want as we get older we
still have our health it may not be the
same but it's still there but we now
have long wealth we have more money we
have a home we have devices and
possessions we have a car we have access
to things but we don't always have time
money can buy a house and
it can buy a bed but not sleep it can
buy a book but not knowledge money can
earn a title but not respect you can buy
a clock and not time
those of us who think we have no time
for our health will sooner or later have
to find time for our illness when we're
young we had time and health but no
money when we're older we have money and
health but no time and finally in old
age
we have money and time but no health to
use that wealth so what do we do we can
have it all
just not all at the same time we place
so much pressure on ourselves trying to
get everything to be perfect trying to
get everything to balance trying to get
everything to work together not
recognizing that it's none of those
things that actually create happiness or
fulfillment in life as we get older time
health and wealth will all be taken away
from us but the one thing that can never
be taken away from us is the impact we
have on others because it lives on
through them and rule number ten the
last one in for a very special bonus
clip is know your biology what time do
you usually go to sleep this is not the
time you went to sleep last night it's
not the time you want to sleep tonight
this is the time you go to sleep on
average wait a minute let me write this
down now I want you to write down what
time do you usually wake up when is it
not just when you're forced to go to
work
what is your natural body rhythm what is
the natural time thing you tend to wake
up write that down now
now tell me using those two numbers what
is the midpoint of your sleep for
example if you usually go to sleep at
10:00 and you wake up at 6:00 the
midpoint would be 2 so figure that out
right now we're looking at us - what is
the midpoint of your sleep so as you can
see from this diagram if your midpoint
is between 12 a.m. to 3 a.m. you're
known as a lark and you're 14% of the
population if you wake up from between 3
a.m. to 6 a.m. then you're what's known
as a third bird these people are 65% of
the population and finally if your
midpoint is 6 a.m. to 12 p.m. that
you're known as an owl you make up 21%
of the population so depending on your
midpoint and your categorization you
will make decisions at better times you
make better first impressions at
different times so if you're a log
remember that was if your midpoint is 12
a.m. to 3:00 a.m. your analytical tasks
should be done early morning your
insight tasks should be late afternoon
or early evening making an impression
the morning is your best friend and
making a decision again it's the early
morning now if you're a third bird which
means your midpoint is 3 a.m. to 6 a.m.
then you do the analytical tasks best in
early to mid-morning you'll do your
insight tasks best late afternoon and
early evening you'll make an impression
in the morning and you make your best
decisions early to mid-morning now
finally if you're an owl and you're mid
point is 6 a.m. to 12 p.m. your
analytical tasks are actually better
late afternoon and evening your insight
tasks are best in the morning you make
an impression best sorry in the morning
and you make your best decisions in the
late afternoon and evening this very
simple framework is either going to give
you assurance that you're making your
right decisions and your wrong
impressions at the right time of the day
or hopefully it's giving you awareness
so that you can start shifting your
thought patterns and start not worrying
about making tough decisions at night
see now if you know that you make your
best decisions in the early morning or
you make your best impressions in the
morning to mid-morning then you know to
reserve those important meetings there's
important conversations till then you
won't now sit up all night forcing
yourself to try and come to a conclusion
because you know that your biology
you'll make up the sleep that you're
getting is dictating when your best and
making a decision try it out for the
rest of the week and let me know what
you find now I've got a special bonus
clip from Jay on how to find your path
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take in
action here we go question number one
how can you fill your cup with positives
number two what rejection do you need to
grow from and number three what's the
impact that you want to make when I was
22 I decided to turn down my corporate
job offers and go and live as a monk in
India for three years and half our days
with silence and half of it was service
so we meditated for half the day and the
other half we were trying to serve
humanity and make a difference in the
world
Wow so that is why you decided to not
just be in India and be a monk you
decided it's better to be able to share
this knowledge
yeah well when I left and came back I
was in debt I moved in with my parents
age 26 and I was trying to figure things
out but a lot of my friends now work to
large organizations and they were going
through stress and burnout and pressure
and so they started to invite me to
speak of their companies about
everything I'd learned as a monk and I
started to do that and I started see in
packed inside these organizations but I
really felt I was like this knowledge
and wisdom needs to reach everyone in
the world it needs to reach further than
just corporate boardrooms so in 2016
only three years ago I started making
these videos which were these wisdom
bytes and thankfully to all of you and
many others who've watched them they
started to spread and Arianna Huffington
was someone who really supported them
and gave me an early tipping point to
if you want more J check out the top
fifty rules video made on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there thank you so much for
featuring my ideas and my thoughts I've
been following you for a long long time
so I'm really excited to see this come
together